so this is britney spears yeah this just
she's supposed to see him
at 2 am i decide to take a bath i get a
new scented lotion
okay who gives a [ __ ] there's a lot of
sleep better okay
went to the bathroom and looked at my
leftover coffee from early in the
morning said grows
but didn't throw it away and then i
looked for my face wash we couldn't find
it anywhere
i was caught up in my head looking for
it for about 15 minutes guys
and then realized it's probably in the
other bathroom
because i live in a mansion then i went
to leave the door and it was locked can
you believe this
i thought okay well it's a bathroom i
can't open the damn
door no the lock was stuck everybody i
got locked in the [ __ ] bathroom
my boyfriend was sleeping even if there
are earthquakes he doesn't wake up
real problem i screamed hey
come open this stupid door silence the
fourth time he gets up and says
what's wrong i said i'm in here i can't
get out silly
he tried to do his thing to open the
door with a pen
so i got my phone called security to
tell them to open the door
50 minutes went by this is so long 50
minutes went by we have finished it
50 minutes went by and they finally said
they'd send someone up to open the door
10 minutes later
hello is anybody there then they told me
10 more minutes
cleaned the bathroom and thought about
taking a shower or something
but then i saw the door i just looked at
it for the first time with a yearning of
just wanting to open
would my eyes trick me and make it open
fat happen faster
my eyes widened the door was more clear
more vast let's see with clarity and
brightness please open the door
we're here they said this is the worst
post of all type
i asked how long would it take to open
and they said oh maybe 10 minutes
the old coffee i had left over from the
morning was there i started feeling
groggy so i drank it everybody
i was re-energized started speaking
again are you guys there yes we are they
said
stand back we're going to open the door
it opened it finally
and miley cyrus said they freed britney
for real
uh holy [ __ ] what yeah but there's a
theory on this
yeah so you know about this post yeah
okay oh wait where's the video that was
that hurt father who has stewardship is
posting [ __ ] to make her look crazy
oh so that the judge will then go
she's not that makes sense because this
sounds like something like crazy person
yes
she got her bra off in one of them yeah
so her father
her father is actually controlling her
i've heard that
yeah but her father posted this her
father sounds like that
her dad said get your tits out i mean
her dad posted that
uh i don't know i don't know but that's
the theory we don't know if you're
running she might not be doing well
she's not allowed to see her own
children is that correct or if she is
i feel these are being posted she's not
a bad person
someone yeah how the [ __ ] did her dad
just feel like we obviously don't know
the whole story but you do feel bad for
her man like if she really wants help
she's a grown
[ __ ] woman man like give her give her
money let her
her conservatorship is her father is
controlling her life so
you would go crazy how is this how is
this guy able to control her life like
that's that's what's crazy because this
is why but but
you know it's in the middle of that
crazy she said tits on her though
is that making her crazy though the
whole thing is weird the whole thing
there
this year's with the pig there's shoes
with the drink
but it's all like it's all like weird
like look at that you're taking a
mother's
uh uh you know a mother away from her
children
right she's not able to she doesn't live
with her children she doesn't see her
children no uh she's she just
sees some visitation rights but not like
my husband has to be there
right so whatever yeah that that will
[ __ ] you up
yeah forever well that means you're
doing all crazies because she couldn't
see your kids
who i was a mama beard yeah i would go
crazy way worse than this yeah
so so and then your father has control
of everything you really
your mind and then they're forcing you
to work and she was like i'm i'm
[ __ ] that i'm not working what is this
he didn't come around to her life until
she was like oh she wasn't even in her
life bad guy
yeah bad i thought she was like guy bad
guy terrible person yeah and
and the judge has given this guy control
over her life i don't know much about
you
have you ever watched the documentary
have you seen it no no i watched some of
it she went crazy over this paparazzi
[ __ ] all the time paparazzi also
shouldn't have
visitation over kids i mean you watch it
like jesus christ this is a good person
this is a good person you were also
telling me that some of those
celebrities set it up to where the
paparazzi do show up
like she wasn't but or maybe her
problems
she was in the gas station you can't
avoid it and they were just like
you can't right at the bathroom you're
trying to take a [ __ ] you would go crazy
can't see your
kids and we're going to be go with a
camera in your face and we're going to
control all your money
i go crazy i go crazy oh yeah you should
feel bad for him yes
yeah why is this chocolate i'd like to
hear what the [ __ ] is this judge doing
that that's what i'm saying
that's what makes it like i want them to
free hashtag free britney all day but
also
i need more of the facts like because we
just see this one side right
and it makes the father seem like such
an [ __ ] but for a judge to grant him
all that conservatives is going on here
something that also knows the ex-husband
that like uh kevin featherline's like
like you don't see him talking i just
don't know what's going on though it
just doesn't make any sense if she's a
danger to herself
yeah we don't have the whole story
though but she's yeah it's a shame
yeah there's there's another that's
worst post i've ever seen in my life
it is pretty crazy right yeah so some
people are saying that's also kind of a
it's probably
a metaphor for her conservatorship and
where her life right now you know the
door's locked she can't do anything but
she wants it to be open and someone
helps her
yes something like that that's like one
of the theories that makes sense
free her uh you're like a human being
she's gonna see her
am i right no hurt hey don't touch my i
don't
feel comfortable with that i mean you
know how hard it is to be
britney oh my god can you imagine
being here that's so hard it's true it
would be a beast
oh yeah and have fine time to work out
and being brittany randomly
her kids are in their teens right yeah
they saw them i'm so nice about that
yeah that whole thing is a [ __ ] buzz
you don't even really get to watch them
grow
you lost your children yeah so as
somebody with
children was [ __ ] nightmare